-Russia launched a full-scale
military assault
on Ukraine last night
that shocked and horrified
almost everyone in the world,
except, apparently,
for the leader
of the Republican Party,
Donald Trump.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
If you are like me or like
most people around the world,
you were watching the news
of Russia's attack on Ukraine
last night
with a sickening feeling
in your stomach,
a mix of grief and sorrow
and despair
at the mass human suffering
this atrocious act will cause.
No one, aside from Putin
and his cronies,
wants this reckless
and illegal war.
Certainly not the innocent
Ukrainians targeted by it,
not the rest of the world
watching it,
and not the hundreds
of ordinary Russians
who took to the streets
to protest,
despite a total ban
on such demonstrations.
So, if you're like most people,
you were shocked and horrified.
But if you were Donald Trump,
apparently,
you were at Mar-A-Lago,
watching it with a bunch
of Palm Beach plastic surgeons
and their third wives
and thinking,
"You really got to hand it
to Vladimir Putin."
[ Guest laughs ]
First of all,
stop talking about everything
like it's a [bleep]
real estate deal.
[ Laughter ]
It's an illegal war
against a sovereign nation,
not an empty lot
in Atlantic City.
[ Laughter ]
Second, if you --
if you ever find yourself
at a fancy,
high-dollar fundraiser,
clinking champagne glasses
while the keynote speaker
applauds
an illegal and catastrophic war
that will cause mass suffering
and destabilize
an entire continent,
maybe take a moment to text
your therapist and ask...
[ Laughter ]
Of course, then your therapist
will just text you back...
[ Laughter ]
...and you won't hear
that text notification
because you'll be yelling
at the waiter about your salmon
or, I don't know, chanting,
"Lock her up," for no reason
[ Laughter ]
because, you know,
you're a bad person.
[ Laughter ]
Trump then went on
to brag, once again,
about how close he is
with the guy
who is currently
waging a violent
and unprovoked assault
on a neighboring country.
But in the process, he,
as usual,
rambled his way into talking
about something
completely different
and pointed out one
of the people in attendance,
GOP Congressman Ronny Jackson,
his former White House doctor.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yikes! I would not want to be
Dr. Ronny in that situation.
[ As Trump ]
My two best friends are
Vladimir Putin,
one of the most reviled men
on Earth,
who is currently in the midst
of waging an illegal war
that has shocked and angered
the entire world, you know;
and of course, Dr. Ronny.
[ Laughter ]
You guys are my best buds,
my crew, Vlad and Ron.
I love them because they're
interchangeable.
[ Laughter ]
Ronny, got up and wave
to everyone,
so they can see the man
I consider equal,
in every way, to Vladimir Putin.
[ Laughter ]
It's like an underling
getting called out for praise
at a Legion of Doom
cocktail party.
"Okay, who's here?
We got Lex Luthor.
Great to see you, Lex.
Brainiac. Welcome, Brainiac.
And, of course, who could forget
Dave from accounting?
[ Laughter ]
Dave, you are just as important
to the Legion of the Doom
as the rest of us.
Let's give Dave a round
of applause.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
While the rest of you are
out there,
robbing banks
and building ray guns,
Dave is keeping the lights on."
[ Laughter ]
If you thought Trump's response
to the crisis
couldn't get any more sickening,
he later called in
to Fox News Live,
as the invasion was happening,
and found a way to connect it
to his unhinged claims
about the 2020 election.
-A month ago or three weeks ago,
all the so-called experts
were saying that, you know,
Putin was probably going
to just be content
with staying
in those separatist regions.
But I think,
given what's unfolded,
sadly, with a lot of weakness
in the United States,
they just decided to go for it.
I mean, it looks like
they're going for it
and where does that leave
the NATO alliance?
-I think you're exactly right.
I think that's what happened.
He was going to be satisfied
with a piece
and, now, he sees the weakness
and the incompetence
and the stupidity
of this administration.
And, as an American,
I'm angry about it
and I'm saddened by it
and it all happened
because of a rigged election.
[ Laughter ]
-How does he do it?
How does he find a way
to connect everything
to his rigged election [bleep]?
It's like his version
of Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see. Putin is from Russia,
just like Black Widow,
played by Scarlett Johansson,
who starred in "Marriage Story"
with Laura Dern,
who is in "Big Little Lies"
with Reese Witherspoon,
who was in the movie "Election,"
which was rigged.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, by the way...
[ Cheering ]
...the same guy who called
our current leaders stupid,
later in that same interview,
got confused and thought
Americans had launched
an amphibious attack in Ukraine,
which he started
complaining about
until FOX host Laura Ingraham
corrected him
and told him
it was actually a report
about a potential amphibious
assault by Russia, not the U.S.
-President Trump.
-Energy independent
and he blew it.
-We're just learning
that U.S. officials
are looking at a potential
amphibious landing, now,
in Odessa, Ukraine.
-That's a very sad thing,
but you know what's also
very dangerous is
you told me about the amphibious
attack by Americans.
You shouldn't be saying that
because you and everybody else
shouldn't know about it.
They should do that secretly,
not be doing that
[ Laughter ]
through the great
Laura Ingraham.
They should be doing
that secretly.
Nobody should know that, Laura,
and, you know,
you or nobody should know.
-No, that was the Russians.
-No, those are the Russians,
the Russian amphibious landing.
-Well,
I thought you said that --
I thought you said that
-No, no.
-we were sending people in.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, okay.
-No, I did not.
-Alright.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Oh, okay, good.
-That would be news.
That would be news.
No.
-And you know what?
That's all we need.
That'll be next, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-That guy was commander-in-chief
of the United States
Armed Forces for four years.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I think, even when we
were in grade school
and they told us anybody
could grow up to be president,
we thought to ourselves,
"Well, I'm sure not anybody.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Timmy keeps going
to the nurse
for chuggin' paste."
[ Laughter ]
But now,
we literally have to admit
it could be anybody.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I'd be surprised
if he even knows
what amphibious meant.
[ As Trump ]
Laura, I was confused
because America, of course,
has the greatest amphibious
forces in the world --
soldiers who can fight with both
their right and left hands...
[ Laughter ]
...which is very useful if you
only have left-handed grenades.
[ Laughter ]
"Um, I think -- I think
you mean ambidextrous."
[ As Trump ] Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Ingraham even criticized
Ukrainian President Zelensky
for pleading with Russia
and imploring them not
to attack his country.
He was desperately trying
to stop
the catastrophic invasion
that would cause misery
and death,
but Ingraham
just didn't like it.
-We had a kind of a really
pathetic display from the
Ukrainian President Zelensky
earlier today, President Trump,
where he, in Russian --
he doesn't like to speak
Russian, but in Russian --
he was essentially
imploring Vladimir Putin
not to invade his country.
Now, we basically have
the Ukrainian ambassador
to the United Nation Nations
looking like a defeated man.
-What would you say is
more pathetic,
trying to stave off
a Russian invasion
that would cause mass suffering
and death
by speaking
in a second language
or having to explain to a former
president live on television
that it was Russia
and not America
who is reportedly launching
[ Laughter ]
a secret amphibious assault
in Ukraine?
I'd ask these people
how they sleep at night,
but I'm guessing they own
a MyPillow,
which means
they don't sleep at all.
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever tried sleeping
on one of those things?
Not only are they filled
with packing peanuts
and broken glass,
but there's also a tiny
little voice box in each one
that plays
soothing sleep sounds
personally recorded
by Mike Lindell.
[ Laughter ]
-We already have
all the pieces of the puzzle.
When you talk about evidence,
we had enough evidence
to put everybody in prison
for life,
300 and some million people,
[ Pop, deflating,
distorted voice fades ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A lot of work went into that.
A lot of work went into it.
You maybe also heard her mention
the Ukrainian ambassador
looking like a "defeated man."
Here's what he was actually
saying to the Russian ambassador
at a meeting
of the UN Security Council,
as the Russian attack
was happening.
-Call Putin, call Lavrov
to stop aggression
and I welcome the decision
of some members of this council
to meet as soon as possible
to consider
the necessary decision
that would condemn
the aggression
that you launch on my people.
There is no purgatory
for war criminals.
They go straight to hell,
Ambassador.
You never hear language
like that at the United Nations,
unless it's Model UN.
Those kids hold nothing back.
[ Laughter ]
For real, one time,
when I was in Model UN,
in sixth grade,
I moved to table the motion
to consider Lithuania's
membership
to the Council
for Ecological Preservation
and the ambassador from Belgium
was so mad,
he put his Capri Sun straw
right through my hand!
[ Laughter ]
I still have the scar.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Went all the way through.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And, even when they're not
openly praising Putin
or denigrating Ukraine,
Republicans have all rallied
around this insane idea
that Biden's "weakness"
somehow invited
Russian aggression.
-To see the way
the Biden administration
has handled Ukraine
is a testament
to a historic truth --
that weakness arouses evil.
-I don't think they know
what they're doing.
-Yeah
-They are in way, way,
over their heads.
I mean, Putin played this
almost like
a symphony conductor
and he had --
and he basically made Biden --
he kind of stretched it out
to make Biden
look more and more foolish.
Now, Putin's an evil man.
-Yeah.
-But Putin is a brilliant man.
I mean, as soon
as Biden came in,
he and Xi said, you know,
"Let's test him.
He looks like a weakling.
He's always been a weakling."
-Yeah. You know,
you def want to get advice
on how not to get played
from the guy
who unwittingly ended up
with the third-biggest
speaking role in "Borat."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, this guy doesn't know
where he is half the time.
You're asking for his take
on a conflict
halfway around the world,
meanwhile, he can't even find
the Four Seasons Hotel
in Philadelphia.
[ Laughter ]
When you asked him about Putin,
he probably thought
you were talking
about French fries and gravy,
[ Laughter ]
which, who are we kidding?
Rudy definitely calls poutine
French fries and gravy.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
French fries and gravy.
I mean, that's a taste
that goes together
like me and my cousin.
[ Laughter ]
We were married.
I didn't know at the time,
but as soon as I found out --
14 years into it.
Anyway,
[ Laughter ]
Joe Biden doesn't have a clue.
Russia's brutal and illegal act
of military aggression
will create
mass human suffering,
which is why the world
must do everything possible
to alleviate that suffering,
including taking in refugees,
helping the innocent displaced
people caught up in this war,
and imposing severe sanctions
to get Russia to stop.
And, as for people
like Trump and Rudy...
-They are in way, way,
over their heads.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.